eu ministers meeting in the
competitiveness council on thursday and
friday recognized the central importance
of industry for boosting competitiveness
and sustainable growth in europe
they agreed on the need to intensify
efforts to mainstream industrial
competitiveness across all policy areas
such as environment climate energy trade
and regional policies
ministers also outlined the importance
of breaking down barriers to industrial
competitiveness such as high energy
bills in europe
we aim to address the high cost
of energy and the lack of a unified
energy market
i believe that this is
probably the most important
priority
ministers also reviewed the commission's
annual growth survey for 2014 which is
the starting point of the european
semester in order to encourage growth
and competitiveness the council stressed
that efforts need to continue in
priority areas such as fiscal
consolidation restoring normal lending
to the economy tackling unemployment and
modernizing public administrations
on the implementation of the european
research area ministers believe that
although much has already been achieved
it is time to step up efforts to promote
a unified research area where
researchers scientific knowledge and
technology can circulate freely
on space matters ministers will scale up
measures to mitigate the risks from
space debris to space infrastructures
such as galileo and copernicus